good morning my name is Katie Whelan I'm
an assistant professor at the University
of Pennsylvania and I'll be talking
today about links between cellular
metabolism and epigenetics I'd like to
first start by thanking the organizers
for the invitation I'm really pleased to
have the opportunity to participate
today in bio conference live and I'd
also like to remind you the audience
that if there are any questions
throughout the presentation please just
click on your Q&A button and type in
your question that'll CUNY that there
are questions coming in and then I'll
address those questions at the end of
the presentation okay so my lab is
interested in understanding how secular
metabolism talks to and regulates
signaling and gene expression and in
particular focus of the lab currently
that I'll be talking about today is an
understanding how metabolism talks to
chromatin and the relevance of this to
diseases including diabetes and cancer
so it's now well accepted that cancer is
both a genetic and epigenetic disease
cancer cells exhibit significant
epigenetic alterations and in fact it's
been proposed that epigenomic disruption
ought to be considered as an enabling
characteristic of cancer cells right
alongside genome instability and
mutation and indeed there's a lot of
collaboration between cancer genetics
and cancer epigenetics for example it's
now recognized that there are a number
of mutations within the genes that
encode epigenetic regulators and this is
important for contributing to the
epigenomic disruption that is observed
in cancer cells however it's possible
that other mechanisms may also
contribute to epigenetic changes in
cancer cells including micro
environmental stimuli as well as
metabolic use so the idea that
metabolism can regulate chromatin really
hinges on the idea that different
chromatin modifying enzymes rely on
different intracellular metabolites
either as cofactors or as donor
substrates
so for example we now know that histones
can be subject to like conservation
their only nak modified this is mediated
by the enzyme open net transfers or Oh
GT which uses the end product of a
pathway called the hexose innate
biosynthetic pathway UTP NSL reposting
and this is coming from a pathway that
branches off from glycolysis so here you
can see these core metabolic pathways
like pollicis TCA cycle and all of these
metabolites deriving from this pathway
so sirtuins rely on nad these are a
class of deacetylases histone
acetyltransferases rely on acetyl co way
as the acetyl group donor jumanji domain
histone demethylases as well as tech
family proteins which are involved in a
multi-step DNA the methylation process
use alpha ketoglutarate as a cofactor
and histone and DNA methyl transferases
rely on s adenosylmethionine as the
essential methyl group donor in addition
a NP activated protein kinase or ampk is
activated under low nutrient conditions
of the cell and mediates sort of an
integrative cellular response to low
energy conditions and as part of this
response actually phosphorylate systems
so you can see how all of these
different chromatin modifying enzymes
rely on different metabolites for their
activity but I think it's really
important in thinking about this to bear
in mind that it's important to consider
which of these metabolites actually
reach levels of the cell at which they
would be limiting or regulatory for the
activities of these enzyme enzymes and
under what conditions are these
metabolites actually becoming limiting
okay so in cancer cells it's now well
accepted that he has results exhibit
really extensive metabolic rewiring in
order to facilitate anabolic
biosynthesis growth and proliferation so
where as an acquaintance cell so may
take up only relatively low levels of
nutrients such as glucose and glutamine
metabolize these nutrients very
efficiently in order to produce ATP
predominantly to oxidative
or lesion to need the cells energetic
needs when a cell receives a signal to
proliferate whether this is mediated by
growth factor binding to its receptor on
the cell surface or oncogenic activation
of signal transduction pathways these
signals will then stimulate the cell to
take up nutrients such as glucose and
glutamine into the cell and these
nutrients will be used not only to
supply ATP but also to supply and by
synthetic precursors necessary for the
cell to grow and divide
so these nutrients will now be supplying
a metabolites needed to produce proteins
lipids RNA DNA basically everything that
the cell needs in order to grow and
divide into two daughter cells
so in essence there's a switch from
catabolic metabolism to anabolic
metabolism and this presumably will
result in changes in the availability of
many intracellular metabolites okay so
we know that metabolism is rewired in
cancer cells and we know the chromatin
modifying enzymes require metabolites so
if the fact that chromatin modifying
enzymes require metabolites meaningful
for the biology of the cancer cell so
this is something that we're thinking a
lot about these days and I think a
number of questions that are important
to bear in mind when thinking about this
include you know which metabolites
actually have the potential to become
limiting or regulatory for chromatin
modifications
how does nutrient availability to the
cell or uncle Gene induce metabolic
reprogramming alter the availability of
these metabolites and then functionally
what does this mean does metabolic
regulation of chromatin have an impact
on tumor growth and is it possible that
some tumor enabling epigenetic
alterations could occur in part due to
antigenic metabolic reprogramming
so my lab has focused thus far primarily
on acetylcholine metabolism and the
regulation of histone acetylation and so
this is what I'll be focusing on for the
remainder of the presentation today okay
so a CoA in mammalian cells is
compartmentalized into mitochondrial and
nucleus cytosol with pool
and so in order for a cell to generate a
CO CO a outside of the mitochondria
there's really two enzymes that are
predominantly responsible for this one
is the coa synthetase or ACS which
produces a seat away from acetate and
the other is ATP citrate links or ACM
which produces acetyl co a from citrate
so it's a CL that's really responsible
for generating the nucleus cytosol with
pools of acetyl co a that derived from
nutrients so in order to get nucleus is
ala cocido Kawai from glucose for
example glucose has to enter the cell
come in through glycolysis to generate
pyruvate primary enters the
mitochondrion is converted to acetyl co
a acetyl choline and convinces with
oxaloacetate to make citrate and citrate
can either be oxidized from the TCA
cycle or can be exported back out of the
mitochondria to the cytoplasm where it
can be cleaned by ACL to regenerate
acetyl co a outside of the mitochondria
okay so one Co Co Co a is generated
within a nucleus cytoplasmic compartment
it can be used either to support lipid
synthesis it's an essential building
block for fatty acid and cholesterol
biosynthesis or it can be used for
acetylene reactions okay so a few years
ago while I was a postdoc and Craig
Thompson's lab we wanted to address the
question ten acetylcholine levels
actually limit the ability of the cell
to conduct a set elation reactions and
we decided to address this in the
context of histone acetylation so as a
reminder the nucleosome is the
fundamental packing unit for chromatin
it consists of about 146 base pairs of
DNA wrapped around histone octamer which
contains two copies each of histone h3
h4 h2a and h2b now these systems have
these n terminal tails that extend out
from the nucleosome and these are
subject to different post translational
modifications such as methylation
phosphorylation glycosylation and a
settle agent now acetylene is important
for activation of gene expression it
also plays important roles in DNA damage
repair and DNA replication
okay so in the Federation of histones
actually limited by acetyl co a
production so to address this question
we did actually a very simple experiment
we simply silenced the two enzymes that
that make nucleus light a solid cocido
COI and then looked at overall levels of
histone acetylation so here you can see
we've silenced ECL and acs and then
looked at overall histone acetylation
and I think what you can clearly see
here is that when you silenced a CL
there's very pronounced decreases and
overall levels of histone acetylation we
saw modest decreases when we silence ACS
and even more pronounced decreases only
silence both of these enzymes now when
you consider that we're not looking at
site specific effects here we're looking
at overall levels of histone acetylation
I think it's really actually incredible
that this dynamic range of regulation
can be achieved by ctul Kawai
availability now we can also show that
if we supplement cells with acetate
which is the substrate for ACS we can
rescue the defect in histone acetylation
in the absence of ECM but not any
absence of ACS conserving confirming
that this is where I deleted by an
acetyl Kawai availability so we've shown
that yes a see Vocaloid production has
the potential to become limiting for set
elation in mammalian cells that at least
under standard culture conditions ACM is
the main source of acetyl co a for
histone acceleration but eazy-e's can't
substitute for ACL when its substrate is
supplemented and certainly the relative
importance of these two enzymes is
likely to be dependent on cell type
tissue type and environmental conditions
now we also showed in this study the ACM
which was previously thought to be
really just a cytoplasmic and I actually
is present both within the nucleus and
the cytoplasm we showed us here you see
egfp kinase young and then here using
biochemical fractionation the endogenous
ACL you can see is present both in the
cytoplasm and in the nucleus as of acs
so this suggests the possibility that
nuclear production of acetyl co a might
be important for the regulation of
nuclear acceleration events okay so so
far
I've shown you that if we get rid of the
enzymes that make of Sirocco way we can
regulate histone acetylation but is that
normal physiologically relevant can
nutrient availability also regulate
histone acetylation and indeed it can so
here you're looking at a panel of glial
blastoma cell lines culture that this
should say here millimolar glucose so
here looking at one two four and twenty
five mill and molar glucose in each of
these different cell lines and i think
what you can clearly appreciate is that
there's a nice dose response to
increasing glucose availability
indicating that the availability of
glucose could be regulating the
availability of a seat away for
regulation of histone acetylation now
we've done some other measurements and
ln two to nine cells cells are fully
viable under each of these conditions
that we're looking so this is not you
know the suppression of histone
acetylation it's not due to cell death
we do see a slowing of doubling time
when we go to 1 millimolar glucose but
between 2 and 25 doubling time remains
the same indicating that these effects
are not simply secondary to
proliferation we also see that goomy
uptake another important carbon source
for cancer cells is increased as we
restrict glucose availability probably
this is important for maintaining
bioenergetics and viability under lower
glucose conditions but clearly this
increased uptake of glutamine is not
sufficient to sustain histone
acetylation levels under these
conditions we can also show that this
glucose dependent regulation of histone
acetylation is dependent on ACL as you
see here this nice glucose dependent
increase in histone acetylation is
essentially blocked when we silence ECM
ok so we've also measured acetyl co a
levels to see whether they are
dynamically regulated by compose
availability and regulated within a
range that could plausibly impact the
activity of lysine acetyltransferases so
here we take an Ellen 2 tonight we lost
Emma cells and cultured them for 24
hours in either 10 millimolar high
glucose or 1 millimolar low glucose and
I think what you can appreciate here is
that acetylcholine levels in the cell
are dynamically regulated by nutrient
availability they're going up to about
12 micro molar and high glucose
conditions run down to about 2 to 3
micro molar and low glucose conditions
we've also measured the product of the
half reaction coincide a free coenzyme a
and you can see that that's sort of in a
similar micromolar range to acetyl co a
in the cell tends to increase with
nutrient restriction and then when we
look at the ratio of acetyl co a to co a
you can see that this is about 1.5 to 2
in high glucose conditions but then
falls well below 1 under low glucose
conditions and the reason we look at
this ratio and we think that this ratio
is important to the cell if you look at
some of these different a subtle
transferase enzymes like gcn5 or ISA 1
which is the homologs of humans have 60
you can see that these are um you know
different cam or Katie values for acetyl
co way but many of these enzymes that
have been implicated in glucose
dependent regulation of histone
acetylation like gcn5 are subject to
product inhibition by Co a so here you
see Katie for acetyl co a 8.5 micro
molar for the yeast gcn5 and a ki for Co
a 6.7 micro molar so these aliens are
very close suggesting that it really
should be the ratio of these two
metabolites acetyl co and co a that
matters to the cell in terms of
regulating histone methylation okay so a
quite major question that we're very
interested in now is can aqua gene
induce metabolic reprogramming actually
alter the epigenome of cancer cells so
you can imagine for example the pi3
kinase Akt pathway is over activated in
a high percentage of human tumors and
has a number of effects on metabolism it
both stimulates the uptake of glucose
and regulates by colonists at multiple
levels and akt can also directly
phosphorylate and activate ACM so this
point might be predicted then to
regulate acetyl co a production to
support not only what
but also acetylene reactions similarly
scenic is a major transcriptional
regulator of metabolic reprogramming in
cancer cells and it both up regulates
glycolysis and glutamine olace us
suggesting that it's likely to regulate
against the availability of metabolites
such as acetyl co a so this is something
that we're actively investigating right
now and hope to have some answers for
you in the near future I also do want to
point out that silencing of a CL is well
known to inhibit the proliferation of
cancer cells as well as inhibit the
growth of xenograph tumors this has been
largely ascribed to the effects of ACL
on supporting de novo lipid synthesis
however I think it's also plausible that
effects of ACL on epigenetics could well
therein on some of these proliferation
effects as well there's also something
that we're investigating and I hope to
have some more answers to this question
and in the near future
okay so at this point I'm going to
switch gears and talk about some of our
work looking at cellular differentiation
and particularly fat cell biology okay
so the model system that we're using
here is 3 T 3 l1 adipocytes so this is a
cell this cell system that produces
fiberglass like pre adipocytes these
cells can be grown into confluence and
then treated with the hormonal cocktail
that stimulates the cells to activate
this transcriptional cascade that allows
the cells to differentiate over a course
of several days into a dipa site so they
take on this rounded morphology
accumulate fat droplets and Express fat
specific genes and one major reason why
we're using this system is because
there's a very clear increase in global
levels of histone acetylation that
occurs during the differentiation
process and this is dependent on ECM so
here you can see that in days 0 premium
to the sites you have histone
acetylation relatively low for days into
differentiation a very clear increase in
overall histone acetylation and if we
silence ACL this is
duction is completely lost in addition
if we supplement cells a CL sanguine
cells with acetate which again generates
acetyl co a we and the other endpoint
ACS we can rescue this effect in histone
acetylation indicating that this block
in histone acceleration is due to the
availability of acetyl co a rather than
perhaps something else that easy on
might be doing okay so this is a fairly
pronounced decrease in overall histone
acetylation models so the first thing
that we wanted to know is whether we're
impacting the differentiation process
are these cells still able to
differentiate if you can't induce this
huge increase in overall histone
acetylation and so one parameter that is
frequently used to assess
differentiation of adipocytes is
accumulation of ribbon so here you can
see oil red Oh staining here at the
stained each of the the sames unusual
that such as triglycerides you can see
how in an individual cell here each of
the lipid droplets are stained bread and
the middle you see the nucleus and when
you look on the level of the whole plate
you can see that there's a lot of lipid
accumulation the cells have
differentiated well and accumulated a
lot of Lebon if you silence a CL there's
quite a lot less look good and if you
assignment it's yes there's a little bit
less leaven
but as I've emphasized throughout this
presentation acetyl co a of course is
not only important for a set elation but
also for lipid Genesis so in that sense
it's not particularly surprising that if
we get rid of a CL we see a less 11 so
then in order to distinguish between
whether a CL silencing is suppressing
differentiation or whether it's
inhibiting differentiation as a whole
with with the gene expression patterns
and products who are surprised what we
found is that differentiation gene
expression patterns are more or less
relatively intact so did the phrase
specific genes like California and ap to
get turned on basically a relatively
normally even in the absence of a CI
although we did notice that a subset of
genes for example gluten for which is
the insulin response of glucose
transporter and adipocytes is regulated
in an ACL dependent manner so its
initial observation that group or
expression is dependent on ACL
during ad pajamas when it's the
hypothesize that perhaps other genes
involved in glucose metabolism might be
similarly regulated by hey see ya
and this actually turned out to be the
case so here if you go down the
glycolytic pathway you look at group
four hexokinase phosphofructokinase
lactate dehydrogenase you can see that
indeed if you silenced ACM you have
substantially lower levels of each of
these Glagolitic genes and expression
can be rescued with acetate indicating
that expression of these genes is
regulated by the Co point availability
we saw the similar pattern for other
genes of G ot Rana transaminase CH OB PG
transcription factor involved in
metabolic gene expression but not the
whole program as a whole
we've gone back subsequently and done
microarray profiling on these cells and
really it's about five to ten percent of
adipocyte specific genes that seem to be
regulated in an ETL dependent manner and
these are indeed enriched for genes
involved in glucose metabolism okay so
is his sonís elevation responsive to
glucose availability and adipocytes as
well so you can see lipid accumulation
certainly is depending on how much
glucose you provide they accumulate more
lipid and histone acetylation follows
this as well so more providing more
glucose a acetylide histones more and
you can also bump up levels of histone
acetylation relate any dose of food
books by supplementing cells with
acetate so these data suggest that
histone acetylation levels really are
highly dependent on availability of
acetyl co a in some how about gene
expression does that follow nutrient
availability as well so indeed these
genes that we've identified as acetyl co
a regulated genes indeed show this nice
glucose dependent regulation in terms of
their expression and this is dependent
on ECM and we saw this for each of these
glycolytic genes that we examine so this
suggests that changes in nutrient
availability are reflected in gene
expression and that a CoA is an
important mediator of nutrient dependent
gene expression so then then suggested
to us a model whereby metabolism
regulates histone acetylation and gene
expression in
ECL dependent manner so glucose comes
into the cell is metabolized through
glycolysis generating pyruvate pyruvate
comes into the mitochondria is converted
to acetyl Kawai condemns us with
oxaloacetate to make citrate citrine is
an exported out of the mitochondria
cleaned by ACM either within the
cytoplasm or the nucleus they generate
acetyl co a that can then be used by
acetyltransferases and binds to a
satellite histones we know that this at
least correlates with expression of a
subset of genes involved in glucose
metabolism such as gloop for suggesting
that there may be this positive feedback
loop whereby glucose metabolism is
regulating metabolic gene expression the
precise mechanisms through which a CL is
regulating gene expression we don't
fully understand and this was an active
area of research so so this study
obviously leads to a number of questions
one of those questions that I'll be
telling you about in sort of the next
section of my talk the next story I'll
be telling you about addresses the
question of whether a CL regulates only
histones or doesn't regulate other
nuclear proteins as well and so this
story really stems from an observation
made by a technician in my lab tatiana
Lozano genteel that levels of another
important chromatin modifying enzyme DNA
methyl transferase one are regulated by
a co during a dipper sized
differentiation so here you can see
looking at dnmt1 levels there are high
in pre adipocytes and become down
regulated during attaboy Genesis here
look comparing days there are creative
insights to cells for days and hood
differentiation process you can see
dnmt1 levels decrease and that will be
silenced ACM dnmt1 levels are at least
partially restored we think this is
happening at a place transcriptional
level since the NF C when mRNA levels
are not higher when we silence ACM okay
so taking a step backward what its DNA
methylation this is basically the
addition of a methyl group to the 5
position on the cytosine right this is
typically occurring in cpg dinucleotides
within June for Mars and is associated
with gene silencing
so there's really two main forms of DNA
methylation de novo methylation which is
mediated by dnmt3a and 3b and then
maintenance methylation which is
mediated by dnmt1 mm-hmm so cnn's you
won't actually associate with the
replication machinery at the replication
fork and is responsible for maintaining
patterns of DNA methylation during DNA
replication gnc1 is also known to be an
Isetta protein okay so we hypothesized
that dnmt1 might play a role during a to
the site differentiation because there
is a role for DNA replication during a
to the site differentiation at least in
the 3t 301 model so as I told you cells
are grown as complements at this point
they are growth arrested they are then
treated with a hormonal cocktail
when this happens cells actually
re-enter the cell cycle and undergo
about two rounds of cell division before
they arrest and then go towards terminal
differentiation so it looks kind of like
this cell number between about sixty
twelve and sixty hours after inducing
differentiation some number roughly
quadruples simply means and then that at
dnmt1 is playing an important role
during this time frame which is called
mitotic clonal expansion that yet that
DNA methylation patterns would be
maintained
whereas if dnmt1 was not playing an
active role here they would likely be
diluted out during this period so we
further explored DNA dnmt1 expression
levels during adipocyte differentiation
here do you see get into one mRNA levels
you can see that 24 hours after ins you
see any differentiation which is doing
this mitotic criminal expansion period
dnmt1 levels are elevated and and then
they are suppressed later during
differentiation people are gamma is the
master regulator of attica genesis and
as expected gets turned on during
differentiation and the NMC 3a and 3b
show different patterns of regulation
during differentiation
if we look at dnmt1 printing models you
can see that protein levels also follow
mRNA levels during early alpha genesis
getting turned on here
by 24 hours and then coming back down
later and differentiation and almost
disappearing so we think there's really
two levels of regulation here a
transcriptional up regulation during a
mitotic criminal expansion and then down
regulation and then a further protein
level suppression of dnmt1 levels that
occurs later on zouri differentiation to
essentially get rid of the NMC one it's
this relevant at all in Eva well we
think so
in this experiment we fractionated mouse
adipose tissue into adipocyte and
stromal vascular fractions the sermo
back to the vascular fractions contain
pre adipocytes and you can see that
dnmt1
is present here in a stromal vascular
fraction but not in the adipocyte
fraction suggesting that it is also
suppressed and during aleppo genesis in
vivo okay so Doug be an MC one play
active role in maintaining DNA
methylation patterns during the dip
aside differentiation so to address this
question we've performed by sulfite
sequencing in control and dnmt1 silence
the lymphocytes over the first four days
of differentiation so here you're
looking at triplicate samples in control
cell that they 0 2 & 4 of
differentiation and si dnmt1 samples at
the 0 2 & 4 and here you're looking at
individual CPGs at the glute 4 locus and
here at the P part gamma locus so two
genes that are turned on or inhibit
aside differentiation and I think what
you can pretty clearly appreciate here
is that in control cells methylation
levels more or less remain constant over
this differentiation process there are
really very few changes occurring here
but when you silence the NNC one there's
a very pronounced decrease our
devolution of DNA methylation that's
observed most strongly between the zero
and two of differentiation which is
consistent with this mitotic normal
expansion period and we see this both
for CPGs at gluten form and a P part
gamma so this tells us that yes dnmt1
actively maintains DNA methylation
patterns during early adipocyte
differentiation we also looked at
histone methylation and we've looked at
h3k9 dimethyl by a chromatin
immunoprecipitation
the reason we did this is that the
methyltransferase g9a
also is known to associate with dnmt1 at
the replication fork and it's involved
in maintaining histone methylation
patterns during replication as well and
so we also look to see whether
h3k9 dimethyl was also regulated if we
suppress be an empty one and he did see
reduce levels of h3k9 dimethyl at genes
such as ipv4 include four which are both
genes turned on during differentiation
okay so does the NMC one then
functionally regulate adequate genesis
so interestingly if you look later on
during differentiation if you look in
the differentiated cells they appear
relatively normal
if you silence the NMS you wanted and
differentiated the cells but if you look
accompanied in differentiation there's
actually a really striking phenotype
that pops out and that is that these
cells are differentiating early so here
you're looking at cells tuning in to
differentiation this is a both dippy
lipid dye you can see the lipid droplets
here and control cells were we there's
almost no detectable lipids that can be
observed at day two you can see what
that's clearly by day or apply but at a
- you really are not seeing in what
those in the control cells whereas when
we found on CNN c1 you can employ only
see the cells are beginning to
accumulate with the droplets early gene
expression patterns follow this you can
see many of these adipocyte specific
genes are expressed at significantly
higher levels and they - a
differentiation if you sign less dnmt1
I will emphasize though that cells
actually maintain I'm not a bollock
function after dmc1 silencing they
actually still undergo mitotic criminal
expansion all that we do see a little
bit of a suppression of overall cell
number with dnmt1 silencing and they
maintain the ability to take up glucose
insulin responsive glucose uptake is
essentially normal
in differentiated cells after dnmt1
silencing it's just that they're
differentiating a bit earlier okay so
then we wanted to understand how dnmt1
is regulated by ECM and so it's been
previously reported in the literature
that
MC 1 is Isetta lated and that this
regulates its stability so dnmt1 is
Isetta lated by the hat tips 60 this
promotes its association with an e3
ubiquitin ligase removing as you think
relation and proteasome integrin so you
know this seems to fit well with what we
were observing here a cell silencing
would reduce the availability of acetyl
Kuwait at tip 60 and impaired the
ability to assemble a dnmt1 this should
result in higher levels of DNC 1 so this
seems to fit well with the effects that
we were observing so we had competence
at ACL my view regulating the set
elation of dnmt1 however we've also
observed in previous studies that
certain proteins are a simulation of
some proteins is responsive to metabolic
state of the cell whereas the salvation
of other proteins is not responsive to
the metabolic state of the cell like p53
is that elation for example in response
to DNA damage does not seem to be
responsive to ACL and levels of acetyl
co a in the sub and likewise when we
examined DNC wesat elation to a great
frustration it turned out that dnmt1 a
subtle agent levels do not seem to be
sensitive to ACL or to acetyl co a
availability here you see if we
supplement acetate the NMC want a set
elation remain largely intact if we
silenced ACL we also see that there's
almost no kanji on so you want to set
elation so this led us to hypothesize
that some other mechanism could
potentially be at play here so what's
another mechanism to regulate protein
levels well we thought perhaps micro
rna's might be worth a look here so look
into a little bit that sure told us that
there have been a number of micro RNAs
that have already been identified to
regulate dnmt1 either directly or
indirectly and when we cross-check this
then with micro RNAs that are known to
be insert induced during a dip of site
differentiation we found that there was
one overlap here so micro RNA 148 a is
induced during a dip the site
differentiation and it has also been
previously published to directly bind to
the
utr of dnmt1 henry press it so we
thought looking at micro RNA 148 I might
make sense here so we found that mere
one for a a was indeed induced during
adipocyte differentiation and this
occurred over a similar time force to
suppression of dnmt1 protein levels we
also very excitingly found near 148 a
levels are induced during
differentiation in an ACL dependent
manner so if we silent ACL near 140
today does not get induced we can also
rescue it at least partially by
supplementing cells with acetate
indicating at Maron 148 a maybe one of
these acetyl co a regulated genes so
Kenya 148 a also regulate dnmt1 levels
in at the sites so here we top eclis
expressed near 148 a in creative a sites
and then differentiated the cells and I
think what you can appreciate is that
particularly obvious here at day one and
day two of differentiation which is
again during that mitotic clonal
expansion with the ends you want it so
important
Jorma 48 a significantly reduces levels
of dnmt1 so Milla 40 they can regulate
dnmt1 during it was like differentiation
okay so what happens when we overexpress
neon 148 a what effect does this have on
Deficit differentiation well we were
really excited to find that actually
this also accelerates adipocyte
differentiation so again here we're
seeing with over expression in your own
forty day early turning on of these fat
specific genes as well as early and
greater accumulation of lipid droplets
in new cells so you can see that's very
clear here plenty of a little bit
droplets here and in normal for you they
express themselves whereas if they to
you really have no lipid droplets in
your control cells so just like silent
think of dnmt1
expression of your 148 a which targets
the NNC one can also accelerate the
deficit differentiation so this suggests
that something interesting to us about
the type course so it's thought that
this period of mitotic 100 expansion is
sort of temporarily separated from the
process of differ
so cells undergo cell division growing
the rest and then go towards terminal
differentiation but what we are
observing is that cells are accumulating
lipids early at clearly by they to
differentiation all cells are still
finishing up with my top mitotic clonal
expansion they're clearly expressing fat
specific genes and clearly accumulating
love it already
so this led us to wonder about the time
course here and whether these perhaps
might actually be overlapping processes
so ourselves that are accumulating
lipids actually able to undergo cell
division at the same time and so to
address this question we've actually
filmed these cells live and so here you
can see some still shots from this movie
each of these little black dots here is
lipid you can see here if you follow
this cell you can see it then divided
into two daughter cells and then here
this red arrow is pointing to another
cell that you can see if you follow that
also dividing into two daughter cells
so clearly lipid droplet containing
cells are able to actually undergo cell
division the lipid accumulation is not a
barrier to cell division in these cells
so now to show you the the movie are
actually live let's see can we bring up
the movie ok I'm not seeing the movie so
we'll just move forward ok so
unfortunately
you
I've shown you that these cells are able
to I've shown you that these cells are
able to differentiate relatively
normally even if we silence the NMC one
why do cells have this mechanism in
place to suppress to suppress early
turning on of identified specific genes
if you know cells are ultimately able to
differentiate normally anyway
well I think one reason that this might
be the case is that in vivo we know that
precursor cells actually expressed the
master regulator of Agua Genesis which
is P power gamma
people are gamma is necessary and
sufficient for out of a Genesis and but
but yet these cells in vivo presumably
do not undergo differentiation until
they receive an appropriate q to
differentiate so perhaps because these
cells have the NF C one maintaining
methylation patterns on those to the
site specific genes that keeps those
cells in check in order to prevent sort
of precocious or inappropriate
differentiation without receipt of
appropriate cues and I think this
interpretation is consistent with some
classic work done by Taylor and Jones
back in the 1970s
so Taylor and Jones were working with
the mesenchymal cell line C 3 H 10 C and
a half cells and they found that when
they treated these cells with DNA
methylation inhibitors like five days of
sided beam and then left them in culture
for an extended period of time for a few
weeks what they observed is that
spontaneous differentiation actually
occurred so they observed adipocyte
patches of adipocyte differentiation
myotube differentiation so something
about DNA methylation seems to be
holding these differentiation programs
in check okay so now I've shown you that
both silencing of dnmt1 an expression of
Mir 148 a can promote a to the site
differentiation but I've also shown you
the same thing of dnmt1 basically wipes
out levels of the NMC one of them cell
was mere 148 a just reduces levels of
dnmt1
and yet they have comparable effects on
promoting differentiation so this led us
to suspect that perhaps Mira 1:48 like
many my party is is probably regulating
a target a network of targets in order
to mediate its effects on
differentiation so here we've both
expressed min 148 a and silenced the NMC
1 and you can see that there are in fact
additive effects of these two which
suggests that Maryland 40 a day is
hitting other targets in addition to the
NFC one although we don't yet know what
those targets are okay so next we wanted
to know what their near 1 for DNA might
be able to rescue effects of hyper
methylation now we know from the
literature that hyper methylation can
suppress a dip a site differentiation
and this actually comes from literature
studying isocitrate dehydrogenase
mutations so Isis the trait mutation did
isocitrate dehydrogenase 1 & 2 occur in
certain types of cancers including
gliomas and leukemias so IBH 1 is a
cytoplasmic environments produces NADPH
converts isocitrate into applicative
blu-ray and IV h 2 is a mitochondrial
enzyme that does the same thing verbs
isocitrate into alpha to be literate in
an atp-dependent manner so what happens
when cells when ith becomes mutated is
that the mutant protein loses its wall
type activity and acquires a novel
activity whereby it converts alpha
ketoglutarate into the metabolite two
hydroxy glittery in an NADPH dependent
manner now what happens when when any
cells have these ideas mutations they
accumulate very very high levels of this
metabolite two hydroxy twittering now
two hydroxy butyrate can actually
compatibly inhibit certain alpha
ketoglutarate
and enzymes including jumanji domain
histone demethylases
and tet family 5-methylcytosine
hydrolysis so this ultimately results in
a hyper methylation phenotype so hyper
methylation of histones and DNA is
observed in tumors that have these idh
mutations
these tumors also exhibit a
differentiation block
so in a study published in nature last
year from Craig Thompson blab to study
the effects of mutant idh on
differentiation the mutant ith M vine
was expressed in the three t3l one into
the site system and what was found was
that ith expression of unit 9 th
actually suppressed a Tabo genesis so
you can see this quote by lipid
accumulation and by gene expression
IDH mean admin suppress differentiation
in these cells
this also resulted in a hyper histone
methylation phenotype in new cells and
the suppression of differentiation could
be recapitulated by simply silencing
histone demethylase enzymes so you can
see here this block of differentiation
and hyper histone methylation so this
indicates that histone demethylation is
actually critical for a demo site
differentiation so we had homicide then
that of Maryland for DNA acts by
inhibiting methylation dmc1 in
potentially other targets it might be
able to reverse ID h mediated
suppression of differentiation so the
rationale goes like this ith mutations
produce two hydroxy butyrate this
inhibits histone demethylation resulting
in histone hyper methylation and
inhibition of differentiation in the
mara 148 a inhibits the foreign
methylation process by regulating GMP's
and one potentially other targets
perhaps it could restore differentiation
in the context of
idh mutation and this actually does work
so here we've expressed me on 148 a in
these cells so here you can see the
differentiation block mediated by the
ith mutations and that initsite
engineered cells we can at least
partially restore differentiation as
shown both by lipid accumulation as well
as by gene expression we also reverse
the hyper histone methylation phenotype
by expressing near 148 a so I can't tell
you anything about whether near 148 a
would have any therapeutic value for idh
inhibit tumors we've used this really as
a tool to examine its role during a
difference a differentiation but look
into the literature tells us that this
might be a particularly interesting
micro RNA
so here 148 a may have general effects
in promoting differentiation it's been
shown in previous studies to be
important for IC class the Genesis as
well as Maya Genesis in addition to and
pajetta since we've shown edgar board
for DNA is also commonly suppressed in
cancer including colorectal breast
pancreatic and liver cancers and in at
least one study in this study on
hepatocellular carcinoma which was
published earlier this year in the JCI
they actually reexpress mere 140 AAA
and this was able to suppress the
epithelial to mesenchymal transition
again suggesting a potential wolf versus
micro RNA and differentiation processes
okay so in summary then i've shown you
that dnmt1 maintains methylation
patterns during early adequate genesis
this period called McSally clonal
expansion i've shown you that silencing
of dnmt1 results an acceleration of
adequate genesis and that dnmt1 levels
are regulated by a neuron 40 regulated
by ACL surprisingly this appears to
occur through ACL dependent regulation
of year 1 for DNA and we similarly show
that a topic expression from year 148 a
suppresses the NM t1 and accelerates out
of of genesis hyper methylation is also
known to suppress adequate genesis and
we can at least partially restore
histone methylation levels and
differentiation by expressing their
marketing there's also data and a
literature suggesting normal for need a
might be a general promoter of
differentiation possibly through
manipulation of epigenetics but further
study of this is certainly required to
understand so with that I will conclude
the presentation I'd like to thank my
lab members the acetyl co a work that I
showed you in the beginning was done by
a graduate student choice Li and
collaboration with Ian Blair's lab at
Penn make Snyder in his lab worked with
her
the dnmt1 here one who did a story that
I showed you was done in March part by a
technician in the lab tatiana lindana
genteel who is now in medical school at
Robert Wood Johnson also with
to get help from another technician the
lab heat was Atum
chalu also contributed from Craig
Thompson club also contributed
importantly to this project as well and
conducted the experiments in the idh
mutant cells we also had help from Eric
witzy and making the movie with your 1.8
a thanks also to my funding sources
thank you for your attention and thanks
to the bio conference live folks for
making this all possible and I'll now
answer some questions okay so let's see
so here we have a question that says do
you think that adipocyte numbers and a
dip of site differentiation rate in
obese people might be affected by
metabolic lengths of the epigenome I
think that's a very interesting question
I don't know the answer to that question
but that's something that you know we'd
really be very interested in trying to
understand further how do I bet diets or
how does obesity regulate expression of
DNS you want on your 140 a day and pre
adipocytes I think it's entirely
possible that we don't know the answer
is it's a great question thank you and
if those are all the questions then I'll
thank you for listening today and I'll
conclude the presentation then thank you